bonsoir et bienvenue dans sa voie en
garde ravi de vous retrouver au sommaire
ce soit on va faire le point sur la
septième vague de coville qui déferle
sur la france la barre des 200 milles 15
jours a été franchi cette semaine le
nouveau ministre de la santé tire la
sonnette d'alarmé sans rendre
obligatoire le masque dans les
transports on ira à gare de lyon voir
comment les vacanciers font leurs
arbitrages verra aussi comment nos
voisins européens gère le retour du
virus dans leur pays le gouvernement a
si la bonne stratégie grand débat à
suivre sur ce plateau dans un instant
c'est la première grande loi antiraciste
en france et elle fête ses 50 ans cette
année nous recevons ce soir alain
terrenoire l'auteur de cette loi dit
pelé veine de 1972 pour la première fois
le racisme devenait un délit en france
alors à l'heure où certains comme eric
zemmour veulent supprimer cette loi à
l'heure où la l on line y prolifèrent
faut-il l'a renforcé faute il l'adapté
nous poseront aussi la question à mario
stasi le président de la licra qui sera
également sur ce plateau dans la
deuxième partie enfin 2 a franchi ce
soir deux partis pris quand la violence
contre les politiques n'a plus aucune
limite richard wehrli va revenir sur
l'assassinât de shinzo abe l'ancien
premier ministre japonais et puis le
voyage dans le temps de thibaut enoch ce
soir edf le grand électricien français
hier aujourd'hui et demain voilà pour le
menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs le répit sur le front du
coc vide aura été court pour françois
braun le nouveau ministre de la santé a
présenté la stratégie du gouvernement
cette semaine de nouvelles mesures
soumises aux députés mais pas de
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire donc inciter plutôt que
contrainte est ce que c'est la bonne
méthode bonsoir professeur bruno mais
gardanne et merci d'être à nouveau sur
ce plateau vous êtes le chef du service
de réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière
à paris bonsoir professeur christian
bréchot vous êtes avec nous à distance
depuis les etats-unis virologues ancien
directeur de l'inserm et de l'institut
pasteur vous présidez aujourd'hui le
global vaille rust network et puis deux
députés pour questionner la stratégie du
gouvernement à john tu es pour la
majorité bonsoir député renaissance le
nouveau nom de la république en marche
député des français établis en asie vous
connaissez cette question du coc judo si
pour cela et bonsoir stéphane peut soit
député communiste de seine saint denis
et membre de la nuque la coalition de
gauche à l'assemblée nationale alors on
commence évidemment avec le tableau
général de cette septième vague dans
soir stéphane bon sens myriam bonsoir à
toutes et à tous si j'ai bien compris
l'été s'annonce à nouveau comme idée
l'oeil de blacko pour commencer
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris myriam c'est reparti pour
un tour on avait cru comprendre que le
virus du coc vite ne supporte pas trop
la chaleur donc on se disait cet été il
va nous laisser tranquilles eh ben pas
du tout le nouveau mariant omicron sont
tombés à 5 ces sons qui n'ont
apparemment il est pas si frileux que ça
et donc on est emporté vers une septième
vague de qu'ovide alors vous avez des
chiffres à nous donner bien sûr ça fait
deux mois que je n'ai pas fait une
chronique sur le cniid mais j'ai gardé
mes automatismes je sais que dans tout
chronique sur le co vide on commence par
la courbe allez hop la courbe regarder
mais qu'effectivement on voit que ça
remonte qu'à une augmentation de ses
fonds une moyenne de la de la dernière
semaine la eu des pics à plus de 200
milles 4 contamination ça entraîne
évidemment aussi un plus grand nombre
d'hospitalisations de gens en
réanimation et même des décès qui on
veut à relativiser un peu aujourd'hui on
en est à plus de 50 décès par jour en
avril il ya eu des moments où c'était
plus de 500 décès par jour est ce que le
nouveau variant est plus dangereux ou
pas suivre la procédure de la chronique
qu vide premièrement la courbe
deuxièmement l'expert donc nous on a
choisi bâle experts officiels alain
fischer c'est celui qui a choisi
gouvernement pour conseiller la
stratégie vaccinale il est immunologue
donc voilà on lui demande son avis il
nous le donne il y a devant nous une
vague il faut raison garder jeu là il
faut surtout moins rentrer dans une
espèce de panique ou d'anxiété
généralisée parce que c'est un virus qui
s'il est là c'est qu'il est plus
contagieux qu'il résiste un peu la
réponse immunitaire mais il n'est pas
plus sévères ils ne prouvent pas des
formes plus grave de la maladie que
c'était le cas au préalable non c'est
plutôt rassurant qu'un discours alors
c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas parce qu'il
n'y a pas de raison de s'affoler qu'il
faut rester sans rien faire évidemment
on l'a dit et répété à le répéter encore
le vide est une maladie dangereuse
notamment pour les personnes de plus de
60 ans âge et puis ceux qui ont des
problèmes de déficits immunitaires donc
quel est le moyen le plus efficace de se
protéger contre les formes de grave dit
que vides je vous entends
évidemment bah oui je suis désolé on se
répète mais c'est le vaccin donc c'est
important pour les plus de 60 ans de se
faire vacciner on est sur lcp profite
pour le dire mais téléspectateurs et si
si si
vous regarderez la moyenne d'âge vous
verrez que c'est vrai mais il ya un
problème le problème c'est alain fischer
lui même qui le mettait en avant en
disant qu'il ya huit à neuf millions de
personnes de 60 ans qui n'ont pas fait
ce rappel et donc qu'ils s'exposent à
des formes graves alors que faire
la fameuse question que faire évidemment
si on vivait en chine tout ça est
tellement plus simple qu'est ce qu'on
ferait bah on confine confinerait tout
le monde pendant deux mois comme ça
s'est fait à shanghai au printemps et on
n'aurait plus droit de sortir on n'est
pas en chine forte heureusement c'est
peut-être ça le problème jamais parce
que nous on a choisi bah si anne on a
choisi le pire système politique enfin
le pire à part tous les autres
c'est-à-dire la démocratie donc le
gouvernement fait maintenant il hésite
un petit peu à prendre des mesures
autoritaires pour pas énerver les
gaulois réfractaires alors que ferme le
pass sanitaires on ne rétablit n'ont
peut-être pas une bonne idée on pourrait
au moins mettre le masque obligatoire à
l'intérieur mais vous vous avez envie de
remettre le masque à pour présenter
l'émission non elle a dit non à anne est
prêt à le faire mais voyez il ya des
réticences malgré tout donc voilà pour
fâcher personne en réalité le nouveau
ministre françois beaune préfère à jouer
sur la prévention en disant oui il faut
faire confiance en français on est
responsable alors je vous propose de
regarder quand il à expliquer ça aux
députés en commission vous allez voir
nous pourrions légiférer sans cesse nous
souhaitons plutôt que chacun puisse être
réactif et toujours adapter ces
comportements à ce que la situation
exige
aujourd'hui c'est clair il faut mettre
son masque dans les lieux bondés
comme ici par exemple il faut mettre son
masque dans les transports en commun il
faut mettre son masque dans les
transports pour les vacances s'est passé
va remarquer le seul qui réagit ugo
bernalicis donc de l'anpp est donc de et
les filles qui prend son masque donc
c'est la bonne nouvelle ils sont pas
dans le blocage à l'effi un conseil de
bon sens dans l'intérêt général ils
veulent bien d'appliquer pour le blu ray
se regarder la photo de l'asld donc
françois bonicel me siècle au masque
tout au bout et ça c'est les gens qui
vient de dire ça serait mieux de mettre
le masque vous rappeler que le premier
cluster à paris c'était la commission
des affaires culturelles assemblée
nationale voilà on va essayer est-ce que
ça suffit de donner un conseil c'est pas
évident d'abord dire de respecter les
fameux cds remettre mon masque que
danièle obono de là aussi ah oui bon ok
on a compris le message je vous laisse
débattre merci à vos risques et périls
évidemment merci pour pour ce didier
merci pour votre regard stéphane je vais
commencer avec vos professeurs mais
carbone dont on a envie de connaître
l'ampleur de cette vague d'été qu'est ce
qui se passe chez vous déjà à l'arrêt
wazières qu'est ce que vous voyez est ce
que les hospitalisations qu'ovide
augmente nettement ou pas alors depuis
maintenant le début juin nous avons une
vague de contamination c'est la fameuse
septième vague essentiellement lié à
l'augmentation de prévalence des 2sous
variant bea cat et surtout b à 5 qui
comme ça a été expliqué on va dire sont
plus comptés contagieux et détourne
légèrement l'immunité acquise
préalablement par la vaccination les
infections antérieures
détourne l'immunité
voilà ils ont modifié leurs protéines
spike et la protéine qui permet au virus
de s'accrocher d'entrer dans la cellule
ce qui fait que la protection acquise
par la vaccination antérieur et bien et
et n'est plus efficace suffisamment
efficaces pour
empêcher protéger contre la
contamination a donc levé efficacement
contre les autres voilà elle reste
efficace avec notamment une mémoire
immunitaire solides pour éviter que la
maladie se transforme entre après en une
forme grave qui amène avec un tableau de
pneumonie à l'hôpital qu'est ce que vous
voyez plus d'hospitalisations plus de
réanimation par voie de conséquence des
unités covin prête à être ouverte ou pas
du tout c'est le pas l'objectif alors
comme tout le monde l'a compris donc on
a une contact des contaminations qui
progresse de façon très importante qui
sont un niveau élevé aujourd'hui 200
mille nouvelles contaminations jours
néanmoins il y à une progression de
l'hospitalisation qui a un niveau
beaucoup plus faible encore mais il y à
bien une augmentation est bien une vague
hospitalière avec aujourd'hui environ
1000 patients par jour qui vont à
l'hôpital et 100 patients par jour qui
vont être en réanimation alors ce qui
change par rapport à vence ça n'est plus
les mêmes tableaux c'est à dire
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
gens qui développent une pneumonie grave
lié au virus ce sont essentiellement des
personnes âgées avec des comores des
comorbidités des maladies chroniques
très sévère et qui à l'occasion d'une
infection par le sar skov 2 kishi
d'autres personnes auraient donné une
pharyngite et un petit rhume et bien
chez elle
déséquilibre la maladie de fonds et
confiance voilà dès qu'on pense à mal
la maladie les le voyez par exemple
quelqu'un qui est un diabète et bien ça
peut décompensé son diabète et bien il
va se retrouver avec des problèmes qui
vont l'amener à l'hôpital voir
animations et donc il ya bien une bague
pour vous donner l'exemple de notre
service et bien depuis une semaine nous
avons eu 7 entrant donc aujourd'hui à
peu près plus d'un tiers des lits
d'hospitalisation qui sont occupés par
des patients infectés par la commune 19
mai alors même qu'il y en a trois qui
sont intubés ventilé donc ça demande
quand même l'importance de la
décompensation de la maladie de fond il
n'y a aucun parmi eux qui à la pneumonie
qu'ovide strict du terme c'est très
clair l'objectif c'est de ne pas
déprogrammer ne pas ouvrir des unités
qu'ovide comme on a vu par le passé
c'est ça ça peut tenir vous avez raison
ce qu'il faut c'est que la pression sur
l'hôpital ne soit pas suffisamment
élevée pour empêcher le fonctionnement
normal alors même qu'on sait qu'on a une
situation dégradée par fermetures de
lits manquent de personnel
l'été avec le départ en vacances et
parfois même l'absentéisme lié à la
contamination du personnel lui-même
malgré ça je resterai optimiste je crois
pour la pour l'été ça devrait bien se
passer car pourquoi parce que d'abord
nous avons des petits signaux très très
réduit a confirmé que nous approchons du
pic des contaminations
on le voit d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays
en europe comme malte israël peut-être
même l'italie où on commence à approcher
premiers
de progression de l'épidémie mais malgré
tout il faut savoir qu'il faut compter
encore quinze jours à trois semaines de
plus par rapport au pic
d'hospitalisation donc pour nous on sait
qu'on va monter on va probalement double
le nombre de patients en réanimation sur
le territoire christian bréchot
n'empêche que on se pose la question et
ont suffisamment armé on avait
l'impression quand même qu'on avait fait
des progrès qu'on était mieux armé vague
après vague la phrase qui dit au fond de
moi je les deuils locaux vides c'est bon
j'ai même eu de deux voire trois fois
elle veut plus rien dire aujourd'hui
cette phrase
alors
effectivement elle s'est maintenant
c'est la situation beaucoup plus
compliquée mais avant je voudrais dire
que ce que vous discutez actuellement en
france et bien sûr absolument vrai au
niveau mondial je réagis en tant que
président du global 27 voix et par
exemple aux états unis on voit la même
chose on voit une augmentation très
importante une augmentation des
hospitalisations et malheureusement
également une petite pour l'instant
heureusement mais une augmentation au
niveau des décès et je pense que la
situation est tout à fait celle qui a
décrit très bien bruno mais garden je
pense que
effectivement l'ailé on ne peut pas dire
actuellement parce que j'ai co vie 19
avant je suis tranquille et c'est vrai
qu'on a une difficulté à se repérer avec
ses différents variant je vais pas
répéter ce qui a été très bien expliqué
on est protégé contre les formes graves
par le vaccin et on est encore mieux
protégés
si on a combiné vaccination et
infections naturel ça ça reste vrai des
dernières études le montrent très bien
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on va échapper
au co vis de moi ce que je voudrais dire
par rapport à
ce vin à ce virus par rapport à abbey à
st tout à fait d'accord sur le fait
qu'ils ne donnent pas pour l'instant
plus de maladies sévères et tous nés ya
un point qui nous inquiète beaucoup
qui n'est pas clair actuellement c'est
celui du co vie de long il ya des études
qui viennent de montrer que avec omicron
vous avez cinq à six fois moins de
risque de faire à kovy de longs que les
variantes antérieur il ya une autre
étude qui montre qu'en termes de perte
de goût en termes de perte d'odorat on
passe de 50% de risque à 17% donc ça
c'est bien nous annonce que le risque
est plus faible mais enfin quand même vu
le nombre très très important de
personnes qui sont en train d'avoir ces
infections je pense qu'il ya un doute je
me présente pas du tout comme une
catastrophe forcément je pense qu'il ya
un doute et à doute qui inquiète et je
pense que quand on réfléchit à ce qui se
passe actuellement ça doit faire partie
de la discussion viendra peut-être sur
les mesures à prendre mais on y va sur
des mesures à prendre mais une dernière
petite question est ce que vous êtes
surpris par la rapidité des mutations de
ce virus on a l'impression que voilà on
va devoir se vacciner tous les six mois
pendant peut-être des années
alors il ya deux sujets lorsque vous
dites vous avez tout à fait raison le
premier c est ce que le taux de mutation
est surprenant non on le voit pour
beaucoup de virus de ce type là mais
vous avez des virus ou vous avez des
mutations importantes mais vous avez des
vaccins dans l'efficacité durent plus
longtemps et là on a un vrai problème à
nouveau c'est que et ça je me permets de
dire qu'on le conte le rappelait dès le
début les vaccins arn ont sauvé des
millions de vies ça a été fantastique et
c'est fantastique
mais comme vous dites on n'a pas pour
l'instant des vaccins qui donne une
protection prolongée
je voudrais la question de du nombre de
doses en fait est ce que toute la
population âgées vers une quatrième dose
une cinquième dose ben x et non c'est la
bonne question est pour l'instant dans
l'immédiat ce qui est clair on le dit
toussaint c'est que après 60 ans quand
il ya des facteurs de risque il faut
avoir la deuxième dose de rappel c'est à
dire la fameuse quatrième dose mais au
delà quand on va arriver effectivement à
l'automne on va devoir vacciner tous
vous savez par rapport à l'être action
tout à l'heure du sujet l'histoire des
variations saisonnières du virus moi je
me permets de dire que en mars dernier
on essayait d'attirer l'attention quand
vous voyez la vue sur le monde entier ça
fait un peu sourire si vous voulez les
prédictions parce que voyez des pays qui
ont des des climats complètement
différent et vous voyez que le virus on
sait bien que ce virus évidemment ça
peut l'influencer mais c'est pas le seul
facteur ce qui est regrettable c'est
qu'en fait on on commence à poser des
questions alors que le coup est parti
cette vague elle est en train d'aller
elle est déjà là et
est prêt à prendre des mesures qui sont
assez simples malheureusement alors
justement puisqu'on a deux députés ici
de bords opposés à allons-y sur sur les
solutions je propose avant de les
égrener de regarder comment les autres
pays justement on fait pour endiguer
cette septième vague masque obligatoire
ou pas pique derrière ou pas tour
d'horizon avec clément méric
le portugal a été le premier touché par
cette septième vague fin avril le pays a
pourtant le taux de vaccination le plus
élevé d'europe et le port du masque est
resté obligatoire dans les transports en
commun et les hôpitaux bonne nouvelle
les contamination diminue depuis un mois
l'espagne ne fournit plus de
statistiques globales elle communique
uniquement sur les contaminations chez
les plus de 60 ans des contaminations en
forte progression ces derniers jours le
masque est pourtant resté obligatoire là
aussi dans les transports en commun les
hôpitaux et les maisons de retraite
principale inconnue l'impact que
pourrait avoir la saison touristique
l'italie est confrontée aux même
paradoxe elle impose même les masques
ffp2 dans les transports en commun mais
là aussi les contaminations sont en
forte hausse ces dernières semaines
le rebond de l'épidémie en allemagne est
plus modérée pour l'instant mais les
hospitalisations progresse chez les plus
de 80 ans là aussi le masque reste
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun le chancelier olaf scholz
envisage d'abaisser l'âge minimum pour
la quatrième dose de 70 à 60 ans au
royaume uni pas d'obligation de porter
le masque dans les transports mais la
septième vague et là un britannique sur
30 a été contaminé en juin contre 1 sur
75 au mois de mai les autorités
envisagent une campagne de rappel
vaccinal pour les plus de 65 ans à
l'automne
agent et voilà on a l'impression
franchement parfois dans cette septième
vague que que le gouvernement relativise
un peu voir minimise beaucoup
d'épidémiologie il faut rendre ce masque
obligatoire dans les transports pourquoi
pourquoi vous le faites pas tout
simplement je crois qu'il faut aussi
savoir s'adapter nous l'avons vu depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs eu ce que vous
décrivez vous voyez que chaque pays a
des mesures sensiblement différentes les
uns des autres ça exprime bien le fait
qu'il faut aussi point des mesures qui
sont recevables par la population qui ce
qu'il est possible de mettre en
application je crois que dans les débats
que nous avons eus même au parlement
nous avons souvent entendu notamment nos
oppositions appelé à la responsabilité
des français on employait mais l'employé
même le mot de vous les infantiliser est
justement là nous les appelons à la
responsabilité
je pense vraiment que tous autour de
nous nous avons dans notre entourage
quelqu'un de fragile et même je dirais
parfois comment pouvons-nous savoir que
quelqu'un autour de nous et fragile
parfois nous ne le savons pas et donc la
responsabilité de chacun c'est bien
d'entendre que c'était suffisamment
diffusé que le gel hydroalcoolique le
lavage des mains reste essentiel le port
du masque également l'aération des
locaux mont blanc est endetté c est plus
facile craignez pas un procès a
posteriori qui pourraient tomber sur les
pouvoirs publics franchement c'est une
dénomination explosait parce que là on
est vraiment dans un moment charnière
avions tous décidés en fonction d'un
éventuel procès on arrête tout on
confine tout le monde on prend cette
décision ce n'est absolument pas la
solution adaptée nous le savons et moi
je suis convaincu que les français
peuvent être responsables on le voit
bien même entre en ce moment dans les
transports en commun vous avez des gens
qui commencent à remettre le masque moi
je les apporte est gelé la la confiance
vous êtes d'accord avec cette stratégie
on a vu dans le sujet qui est des pays
qui garde le masque obligatoire dans les
transports tous les lieux bondés et qui
pourtant voit les contaminations d'abord
on a tous les uns et les autres beaucoup
appris depuis depuis deux ans donc on
est je crois qu'il ya des réflexes dans
la population qui sont désormais acquis
moi j'ai pris le métro chaque jour de
cette semaine et j'ai vu
sens exagérer les deux tiers au moins
les deux tiers des passagers du métro
aux heures de pointe qui avait le masque
sans qu'il soit obligatoire
ce matin sur le marché de saint denis
qui pourtant est en plein air on avait à
peu près peut-être pas la même
proportion enfin tout cas la moitié des
des personnes et notamment valider la
stratégie moi j'ai toujours pensé de
contrat j'ai toujours pensé qu'il valait
mieux convaincre que contraindre et puis
ensuite faut faire faut faire attention
enfin avoir une parole ça j'ai une
parole de conviction parce que ça va on
sort d'une campagne électorale mois
pendant la campagne électorale j'ai vu
beaucoup de personnes avoir être positif
au co vide alors pas être hospitalisé
forcément mais est arrêté d'être bloqués
très fatiguée pendant deux trois jours
et on n'en parlait pas donc on peut pas
avoir mis entre parenthèses voilà qu'il
faut des compromis -
non mais justement je vais on peut pas
voir mis entre parenthèses locaux vides
pendant la période électorale et puis
subitement l'élection terminée
il réapparaît très par miracle donc les
gens sont pas sont pas du
nom mois le chiffre qui m'inquiète je
finis la vaccination c'est la
vaccination parce que les 9 millions de
plus de 60 ans qui n'ont pas de dose de
rappel dans mon département qui apporte
ans et celui qui a eu de plus tôt de
plus fort taux de mortalité sur le co
lead vous avez 30 % des habitants qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant parce que
c'est un désert médical bien que ce soit
une zone extrêmement urbanisées et
comment on voit ce que vous êtes en
dénonçant une nouvelle campagne massive
de vaccination avec je pense que j'aurai
ouvre elle pense qu'il faut faire pour
jouer le rôle qui doit être le sien à la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie à la
sécurité sociale pour aller vers
notamment les plus de 60 ans qui n'ont
pas eu de dose de rappel on sait les
répertorier c'est à la portée de la
caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie faut
peut-être lui donner les moyens d'une
mission spécifique sur le sujet mais
oui ou en tout cas on a une
allée demander quand même aux
hospitaliers aux scientifiques comment
vous vous regardez ce choix de la
confiance qui est fait par le
gouvernement
non non je crois que c'est le bon choix
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement il faut
un équilibre entre ce qui est utile et
ce qui est acceptable et donc
effectivement aujourd'hui imposer le
masque à l'ensemble de la population
serait probablement pas du tout
acceptable et donc je ne serai pas fait
d'ailleurs tout le monde l'a réclamé
tout le monde a réclamé c'est à dire pas
expliqué nous faites nous confiance je
souffre je crois qu'on est dans l'ère de
la responsabilisation éclairé c'est à
dire nous devons expliquer les raisons
de mettre le masque en espace clos
public mal aérée un projet plutôt que de
l'imposer en expliquant évidemment les
dangers alors il faut bien rappeler pour
les personnes âgées fragiles c'est une
protection individuelle et pour les
autres c'est un geste altruiste
on sait aujourd'hui évidemment quand on
est jeune nourrice permettre d'être
contaminé par le le coc u19 en dehors du
coc vie de long mais en tout cas on ne
risque pas immédiatement de se retrouver
en réanimation par contre ben d'abord on
peut avoir quand même des symptômes qui
sont désagréables on va s'absenter de
son travail donc peut-être pas réalisé
l'entreprise et puis surtout on peut
véhiculer car beaucoup de ces infections
sont peu symptomatiques et les gens ne
font pas attention on peut véhiculer le
virus vers son entourage plus fragiles
et donc de ce fait effectivement il faut
mettre le masque dans les lieux où la
contamination est le plus élevé donc moi
je serais plutôt toujours pour la
recommandation maintenant évidemment à
mon sens le danger va nous guetter en
septembre octobre où là on va dire on va
assister à mon avis une vague de
contaminations beaucoup plus importante
ce d'autant plus qu'un nouveau variant
encore plus contagieux est en train de
se développer en inde est très
probablement viendra en europe et si
effectivement la population notamment
fragile n'est pas bien vaccinés si tous
ces messages d'explorateurs est devant
nous en terme de contact annie vert
voilà et puis surtout c'est l'hôpital
lui par contre en septembre octobre va
être extrêmement fragilisée en raison de
toutes les pathologies hivernales
christian bréchot vous qui disiez tout à
l'heure il fallait prendre des mesures
avant les anticiper d'accord avec cette
stratégie ou pas
je pense que c'est
ça qui est terrible c'est
qu'effectivement on est en train de
discuter maintenant après trois mois où
on n'a plus entendu parler de kovy des
on s'étonne du fait que la vaccination
soit difficile à imposer et on est juste
en train de discuter de savoir s'il faut
un masque obligatoire ou non et je pense
que on ne se sortira pas et ça on le
voit très bien dans différents pays on
ne se sortira pas de cette affaire si on
continue à passer par des espèces de
yoyo où pendant certaines périodes ya
plus de co vide et puis brutalement
effectivement on est ramené aux réalités
et ça c'est quelque chose qui se disent
beaucoup aux états unis où il ya des
grosses différences entre les différents
états entre les états du nord entre les
états du sud et là malheureusement il ya
beaucoup de politique et on retrouve les
mêmes discussions mais vous avez des
états aux états unis qui font beaucoup
mieux il faut que laquelle je viendrai 7
pardon quelle est la bonne recette d'un
état exemplaire qui apprend j'imagine à
vivre avec le virus comment ça se passe
alors d'abord il faut dire que il n'y a
pas de solution parfaite on est tous
d'accord sur le fait que c'est pas parce
que on garde forcément le masque que
l'on résout absolument tout ce n'est pas
ce que nous sommes en train de dire mais
je pense que c'est un système n'est par
exemple ça a été bien fait dans des
états comme celui de new york comme de
celui de également dans des états
avoisinants c'est à dire pas un moment
où on a plus de qu'ovide de maintenir
ces discussions sur le masque sur la
capacité de prévention pas forcément
effectivement en rendant obligatoire
mais de maintenir cette discussion de
maintenir cette pression sur le vaccin
de maintenir cette pression sur
l'ouverture sur l'aération de maintenir
une conversation entre guillemets sur
les risques sans du tout faire de
catastrophisme
versus effectivement une situation où
tout a été oublié là on le voit par
exemple je suis en floride c'est un très
bon exemple comme la france 1-2 on a
vécu en floride il y avait plus de co
vide ça n'existait pas ben oui pas
malheureusement on ne peut vite bien sûr
il est la tempe at general hospital
c'est ce qu'a rappelé la situation que
bruno m'égare ban a rappelé pour la
france dont il s'agit absolument pas de
dire que tout est facile et de et de
vouloir toujours de permanence sur le
guide d antan j'entends bah écoutez je
vous propose de rester avec nous masque
ou pas masquer déjà sur cette question
marcon pommier s'est rendu gares de lyon
ce matin pour voir concrètement et bien
les arbitrages que vous allez français
regardez son partage
remettre le masque ou ne pas le remettre
c'est toute la question face à la
recrudescence des cas de co vide
ce matin gare de lyon à paris beaucoup
de voyageurs non masqué dans les trains
un peu moins à la sortie des métros avec
toujours une bonne raison pourquoi vous
ne portez pas le masque dans les
transports bah c'est en fait je pense
que la pandémie en ont donné je pense
que mieux vaut que tout le monde soit
touché et qu'on n'en parle plus que
perdurer en fait avant ni pendant des
mois et des mois et des années moment
donné faut que ça cesse donc voilà non
j'ai pas prendre 29 ans puisqu'on à 5
heures de trajet et fait un peu chaud
d'autres ont fait le choix de se couvrir
à nouveau le nez et la bouche pour se
protéger mais aussi par esprit de
responsabilité
moi je porte le masque parce que en ce
moment le kovy deux circule beaucoup et
c'est important pour protéger les autres
et pour éviter la propagation de
l'épidémie je pense que les personnes
devraient un petit peu réfléchir et voir
qu'il ya autant de cas qu'avant concept
est obligatoire et donc chacun devrait
faire comme il comme nous pensent que
c'est le mieux mais je pense que c'est
quand même bien de porter nettoie cette
semaine elisabeth bornes la première
ministre recommandé de porter le masque
dans les espaces fermés bondé mais pas
d'obligation pour autant une liberté
globalement apprécié chacun choisit
vraiment comme il veut ça aurait dû être
comme ça dès le début au 21ème siècle si
on n'arrive pas à décider ce qu'on peut
faire ah ben merde alors donc chacun est
libre de décider moi je ne porte pas
certains le porte je respecte mais voilà
donc je vois pas pourquoi ça ça doit
changer si l'augmentation de ducobu
d'augmenter on sera bien obligé
d'arriver à une solution il faudra
trouver de solution est la solution la
moins chère la plus facile
c'est le portel masquer le retour du
masque pas encore d'actualité dans les
transports alors que le pic épidémique
pourrait être atteint d'ici fin juillet
d'après les observateurs professeurs
mais gardanne quand vous entendez ces
français on voit que c'est franchement
au cas par cas on est loin des deux
tiers dont vous parliez stéphane peu en
seine saint denis
vous dites quoi sur le métro attention
il faut aérer si les gens restent libres
on ne peut pas laisser dans un huis clos
comme ça sous terre sans climatisation
sans aération des choses vous avez
raison utilisant souvent les métros
puisque maintenant la voiture est
devenue très compliquée à paris je crois
qu il faut augmenter le nombre de rames
il faut mettre l'air conditionné en fait
on connaissait tout ça et c'est là où
effectivement on voit qu'il ya un retard
des autorités publiques pour aider
effectivement à gérer mieux au niveau de
la population l'épidémie il faut pas
uniquement imposer les choses à la
population alors qu'on voit qu'à
certaines heures on est assez dans le
métro il fait une chaleur d'enfer est
effectivement imposé le masque est
parfois extrêmement difficile même si à
nouveau il est recommandé il est utile
pour protéger les plus fragiles pour
terminer ce débat on entend le mot
retard on l'entend le mot mieux
anticiper mais sans contrainte vous avez
entendu professeur m'égare ban le pire
est devant nous et va y avoir
probablement une nouvelle vague je sais
plus là combien tu aimes la 8ème à
l'automne si on fait rien maintenant
mais là où sans état d'urgence sanitaire
on va dans le mur non non non non je ne
crois pas je compte d'abord façon
restrictive les dans la loire l'état
d'urgence n'est pas prolongé pic actuel
est probablement courts ou sous peu on
nous parlons de quelque chose qui
d'autre qui pourrait se produire en
septembre en octobre à l'entrée dans
l'automne moi je voudrais souligner que
lorsque un environnement de travail un
bureau de poste un magasin affiche à son
entrée ici nous portant le masque les
gens le portent les gens le mettent tout
de suite très sage la réforme et six
états seulement si la situation devait
se dégrader nous verrons ce moment-là
vous rendriez un texte de loi qui
permettra des mesures restrictives nous
fait là encore il fait beau c'est que
j'ai bien aimé votre expression trouver
le curseur entre l'utile il acceptable
je les dis tout de suite en introduction
de mon propos tout à l'heure soyons
certains assurent nous d'abord que c'est
acceptable nous verrons bien à l'automne
pour le moment nous sommes sur une
septième vaille un pic est semble-t-il
relativement proche continuant à nous
encourager les uns et les autres à nous
dire que si je ne suis ici je pense ne
pas être utile pour moi je suis utile
aux autres je suis utile aux autres en
portant le masque
si vous voulez d'abord moi j'étais
opposé au régime dérogatoire
sanitaire au régime d'exception parce
que il ya dans notre démocratie tous les
outils pour prendre des mesures rapides
le parlement peut prendre de décisions
en 48 heures c'est ça s'est fait en
d'autres ceux qui nous regardent c'est
vraiment la situation ça déraillait
pérenniser des meilleurs moyens et
mesures d'exception et dérogatoire au
droit commun et au fonctionnement
démocratique dans notre pays moi je
pense qu'il faut du débat à chaque fois
faut discuter et puis il faut des
logiques de convaincre et puis il faut
quand même aussi
se rendre compte dans quel état est
notre système de santé et là il ya des
mesures à mon avis plus fondamental à
prendre pour que chacun puisse avoir un
médecin quand il va voir un médecin lors
de la peine les soignants d'ailleurs le
débat relancé sur le retour des doigts
les soignants non vaccinés avec la crise
coved qui revient est forcément un peu
décalé dernière question pour pour
conclure ce débat christian bréchot au
fond pourquoi ne pas très clairement
acté du fait qu' on va vivre avec cette
épidémie pendant des années et des
années est ce que ce serait pas plus
simple de le dire très franchement à la
population
absolument et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
sorte de effectivement nous verrons bien
à ce moment là j'ai entendu et je
comprends mais tant que ce sera comme ça
quand on commence à s'occuper d'un d'une
vague c'est qu'elle est déjà d'art et
c'était parti trop tard il faut arrêter
il faut préparer maintenant ce qui va se
passer dans quelques mois forcément avec
des mesures hyper contraignantes ce
n'est pas ça que nous disons mais la
discussion le montre très très bien sur
un certain nombre de choses qui peuvent
être faites le virus quand on le voit
avec un pic c'est qu'en fait le pic
était déjà là depuis plusieurs semaines
et on est trop tard je cherche pas du
tout à jouer le catastrophisme et on
comprend très bien les difficultés des
politiques mais c'est quand même la
réalité et cela répond à votre point
oui tant qu'on n'aura pas trouvé des
vaccins qui protège de façon plus
efficace et pour plus longtemps ce que
nous dit cette septième vague c'est
qu'il faut arrêter ce langage où on nous
dit bah écoutez ça va bien on n'en parle
plus et puis on verra bien après dun
compris merci merci pour ce pour ce
message d'invitation et d'anticipation
merci à vous quelque chose me dit qu'on
aura l'occasion de se revoir on va à
présent accueillir nos deux grands
témoins à l'occasion des 50 ans de la
loi dit pelé veine nous sommes ravis de
recevoir son véritable auteur à l'inter
noire il avait 31 ans lorsque jeune
député gaulliste de gauche il a réussi
ici à l'assemblée nationale à convaincre
toute la représentation nationale de
légiférer contre le racisme et grâce à
lui l'injure raciste est devenu un délit
il va nous en parler nous l'invitons
aussi avec mario stasi le président de
la licra alors avant qu'il nous rejoigne
on regarde ensemble cette invitation en
guise de portrait signé mario becker
si on vous invite à l'internât c'est
parce que vous êtes l'auteur de la loi
de 1972 sur le racisme c'était il ya
cinquante ans à l'assemblée ou juives
halte à la negri fication la france aux
français
antisémitisme racisme xénophobie alors
que les incidents racistes se
multiplient avec le premier ministre
jacques chaban delmas vous estimez qu'il
est temps de se doter d'une vraie loi
antiraciste et députés examineront
demain si proposition de loi car le
racisme et xénophobie sont
insidieusement présent dans les actes
les paroles ou les écrits de tous les
jours
dans la presse et les moyens
audiovisuels un délit nouveau se récréer
toute provocation à la discrimination
raciale ou à la haine fondée sur
l'origine ethnique nationale ou sur
l'appartenance ou non à une religion
seraient sévèrement punis la diffamation
raciste également l'injure raciste est
aussi sanctionné et les associations
peuvent se constituer partie civile la
proposition de loi est adoptée
l'unanimité
elles portent finalement le nom du
ministre de la justice pelé veine qui
paradoxalement lui n'y était pas du tout
favorable
à l'occasion des 50 ans de cette loi on
vous invite ce soir avec mario stasi
avocat pénaliste et désormais président
de la licra la ligue internationale
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
depuis 2017 vous combattez toutes les
formes de racisme et de discrimination
une parole indicible ne doit pas être
banalisé et donc la parole publique doit
être impeccable il est difficile
aujourd'hui dans cette hystérie za sion
du débat politique où il ya ceux qui
disent on est chez nous qu'ils aillent
chez eux d'être une minorité en france
oui une lutte incessante pendant la
campagne présidentielle
eric zemmour condamné à trois reprises
sur le fondement de cette loi s'y
attaquer la loi pleven jeu l'abolir est
pour deux raisons très simples 1
elle a été dévoyé par les juges et
parler avec le véritable auteur de cette
loi monsieur terrenoire qui m'a expliqué
que ce n'était pas du tout l'objet que
de faire une loi liberticide comme elle
a été utilisée par les juges de gauche
en réalité alain terrenoire vous n'avez
jamais été aussi convaincu de l'utilité
de votre loi mais on vous pose la
question à l'inter noir et mario stasi
cette loi est-elle adaptée à notre
époque où les discours de haine
bénéficie d'une plus grande diffusion
bonsoir alain ternois re ravis de vous
accueillir sur le plateau de la chaîne
parlementaire avec mario stasi bonsoir
et bienvenue alors avant de vous
demander si votre loi est toujours
adaptée s'il faut la renforcer s'il faut
la protéger un mode de contexte on va
repartir un petit peu en arrière ici à
l'assemblée nationale puisque c'est ici
qu'a été rédigé ce texte il ya
exactement 50 ans dans ses murs vous
êtes un jeune député chaban et premier
ministre et comment vous arrivez à le
convaincre qu'il faut une vraie
législation antiraciste
chaban delmas à convaincre en la matière
ce n'était pas difficile il était de sa
propre nature de ses idées de ses
convictions convaincu de cette nécessité
d'avoir sur le racisme et la
discrimination
une nouvelle législation celles du passé
d'été plus adapté et très peu appliquées
convaincre le garde des sceaux cédait
d'une toute autre affaire
comme une injustice ce que cette loi
porte son nom c'est une erreur à la
limite une faute de da le nom de
quelqu'un à une loi qui ne souhaitait
pas
ce sont les médias qui l'ont ainsi
instruite est annoncée non c'est la
droite 72 comme on dit la loi de 1901 la
loi de 1905 points ça n'a pas besoin de
porter un nom d'autant plus qu'il n'est
pas souhaitable qu'elle soit attribuée à
une seule personne car elle fut il faut
qu'elle soit renforcée complété en tout
cas qu'elles vivent le plus longtemps
possible parce que malheureusement dans
la merde humaine
le mal qu'est le racisme perdure c'est
rare qu'une proposition de loi soit
aussi adopté à l'unanimité comment vous
avez fait ça convaincre tous les bancs
de l'hémicycle
le président de la république de
l'époque georges pompidou il était
également favorable nous avions ratifié
la convention contre la discrimination
raciale l'année précédente il y avait
quand même un certain nombre d'exactions
commises dans la france de l'époque
dix ans après la guerre d'algérie des
comportements d'inadmissible inexcusable
qui faisait que la loi de 1881 et et le
décret loi marchand donne ne répondait
pas correctement à cette situation donc
il fallait faire quelque chose ben
convaincre d'abord la commission des
lois unanimement m'avait désigné comme
rapporteur donc il y avait déjà une
toutes les tendances étaient présentes
ou d'ailleurs tous les partis avaient
déposé des propositions de loi je
n'étais pas le seul à travailler sur
cette orientation
et puis bon bah ça semblait logique
c'était l'assemblée la plus la pub
gaulliste de la vème république est élu
le 30 juin 1968 ne l'oublions pas c'est
peut-être pour ça que certains ont
préféré éluder le nôtre non que le mien
je ne sais pas mario stasi d'ailleurs la
licra est à l'origine de ce combat
législatif alors la licra on fait tout à
fait honnête exo 6 la licra et d'autres
associations un terme bien sûr toutes
les citer mais
la licra dès le décret marchandeau de 36
à considérer que cette cette
réglementation était à parfaire et qu'il
fallait déjà une législation beaucoup
plus solide qui vise à distinguer ce qui
est de l'opinion de ce qui est un délit
et c'est vrai que pendant des années et
des années la licra a oeuvré afin
qu'émerge une loi qui soit peut-être
celle qu'on appellera d'un autre nom que
la loi pleven en tout cas moi je le
souhaite et j'ai ma petite idée
là-dessus mais la licra a beaucoup
oeuvré et continue d'ailleurs à devrait
pour que ce en face de cette loi une
utilisation de dire intelligente est ce
qu'elle est toujours d'actualité cette
loi oui elle est toujours d'actualité
mais je voudrais ajouter à ce que vient
de dire le maître stasi que ce qui lui a
donné une force c'est aussi et c'est
peut-être d'abord le fait que les
associations anti racisme comme la licra
comme le mrap qui fut effectivement
contre un large contributeurs à cette
législation peuvent ester en justice et
pas uniquement les victimes de fer à 6
donc ça c'est un point un point prendre
bien sûr qu'elle était là ce toujours
d'actualité je dirais même que que le
mal du racisme c'est encore plus
répandues comme le feu et une traînée de
poudre et qu'il touche non plus
seulement certains côtés de l'opinion et
mais il s'élargit je vois l'hémicycle
ici derrière vous si je puis dire et
bien de
l'hémicycle et extrême droite extrême
gauche puisque c'est ainsi que depuis la
révolution nous sommes situés dans dans
cet hémicycle de l'extrême lenteur
extrême gauche il y à des courants à
caractère ou
discriminatoire et raciste a remis la
représentation nationale de cette
législature
en fait
d'un comportement font que oui si vous
êtes membre d'une organisation
que vous en êtes l'élu par ailleurs vous
et que vous mousse vous n'avez jamais
démenti des comportements qui sont de
caractère raciste ou qui s'apparente ou
qui s'associe à des mouvements de rejet
de discrimination oui vous en êtes
certainement on va parler des moyens pas
donné d'autre des extrêmes je tiens
quand même
à préciser puisque l'on va pas commencer
à donner les noms de tel ou d'un tel où
les amitiés de tel avec intel mais en
l'occurrence de part et d'autre des
extrêmes ces courants laïcs 6h parlant
son efficacité parce qu'une loi n'est
efficace que si les juges s'en
saisissent sur le terrain elle est
efficace parce qu'elle est utilisée par
la justice il ya des sanctions il ya des
peines qui tombe eric zemmour en sait
quelque chose condamné pour incitation à
la haine raciale mais en même temps son
caractère dissuasif ne marche pas
puisque lorsque j'envoie balles et les
actes racistes proliférer si je puis me
permettre
l'esprit de cette loi c'est évidemment
de distinguer ce qu'est l'opinion du
délit l'opinion c'est ce qui permet une
argumentation une contraire une contre
argumentation
un débat contradictoire un avis
contraire le délit j'ai un exemple sous
les yeux lorsque sur une trame de rer
rame de rer e sujet des maps et je vois
un tag qui le qualifie d' de
en juive et on voit bien qu'on
n'est pas dans le débat on voit bien
pour n'est pas dans l'expression dit
dans l'opinion on est dans le délit dans
l'injure et et cette distinction la loi
l'a fait de façon remarquable mais
l'esprit de la loi c'était pas
simplement de distinguer de sanctionner
c'était et les travaux parlementaires le
rappelle aussi l'urgence d'aider du qe2
forme et c'est à dire que cette loi et
son application ne valent que si le
citoyen est formé
le le juge est formé et former
évidemment mais quand on voit par
exemple cette fresque d'avignon alors
j'ai reproduit les entraînements les
stigmates de tout ce qui existe de plus
antisémites depuis la nuit des temps
vous l'avez apporter ça je vais apporter
parce que ceux qui se les grilles mais
la donne son sens je peux je peux la
montre et s'il ya une caméra je ne sais
pas nous avons ici la fresque de 2022 ou
on voit jacques attali
grossièrement caricaturer manipulant tél
un homme qui manipulent les uns et les
autres
emmanuel macron c'est l'imagerie
populaire entre guillemets antisémite
qu'on le retrouve depuis des dizaines
d'années
1940 1941 en
1909 voilà les trois fresques je voulais
montrer celle de 2022 mois-là 1941 et
voilà 1909 où on a en 1909 dès 1909 un
homme avide avec des des sacs d'argent
et de pièces sonnantes et trébuchantes
qui avec des films manipule tel
l'impérialiste tel homme politique et
c'est la finance il les préjugés aussi
répressif existe les les astres demain
les actes demeure mais ce qui est
intéressant
c'est que les autorités publiques le
grand avignon n'a pas soufflé mot n'a
rien dit il a fallu des actions des
associations et un groupe de pression
pour que sous prétexte de liberté
d'expression les élus certainement par
ignorance 1 10 ans mais c'est la liberté
d'expression il se rend compte en fait
qu'on n'était pas dans la liberté
d'expression mais dans l'imagerie
antisémite ça c'est l'apport de la loi
terrenoir ou lorsque les associations
peuvent se porter partie civile
sur ce sujet des autorités publiques
nous avons un nouveau gouvernement nous
avons à nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale dont on me dit qu'ils
pourraient être sensibles à ce type de
sujets
nous pourrions attendre puisqu'ils n'ont
pas choisi s'est jusqu'à maintenant nous
sommes début juillet de commémorer cette
fois qui a tout de même son intérêt on
commet mortellement aujourd'hui dans
notre jeu rencontre la semaine prochaine
vise
nature essentielle là je pensais qu'on
aurait pu faire peut-être quelque chose
la licra l'a fait dans son assemblée
générale le mrap vient de faire
réellement dans son assemblée générale
2,2 en tout cas d'introduire dans
l'éducation nationale au delà même de
l'éducation civique un enseignement sur
ce qu'est le racisme ce qu'est la
discrimination est d'essayer d'amener
les jeunes à prendre conscience de ce
problème majeur
j'ai interrogé mes petits enfants
ces derniers jours aucun d'entre eux n'a
eu connaissance que ce soit du cp ou au
bac de quelque chose qui s'apparente à
une alerte sur le racisme mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle les associations
comme les nôtres intervenons dans les
lycées dans les collèges dans l'école
primaire pour faire ce travail
d'éducation et de formation
mais je voudrais donc injuste terminé
vous appris sur mon exemple c'est que
vous évoquez l'application par la
justice et par les tribunaux monsieur
alain soral a été relaxé pour un dessin
qui s'intitule est en marche vers le
chaos mondial où l'on voit emmanuel
macron avec un brassard sur lequel il ya
un dollar
pas loin du brassard nazi et derrière
trois figures juive juifs voilà affiché
comme tel est bien le tribunal a relaxé
en disant que 6e et la cour si ce
photomontage pouvait les ti légitimement
choqués ils n'apparaissaient pas
suffisamment claire et univoque pour
viser l'ensemble des juifs ont raison de
leur origine ou de leur religion quand
je vous dis que les musiciens les
ornements de l'application ça pour dire
que les magistrats
ne sont allés je vais être une litote ne
sont pas suffisamment formés voilà je
suis extrêmement prudent c'est dire que
la loi allait elle est bien faite encore
faut-il qu'elles soient bien appliquées
contrairement à ce que dit cet ancien
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
cette loi ll relaxe très souvent et y
compris sur des mots vite au xo prix sur
une motivation hautement contestable
d'accord avec font les juges n'arrivent
pas à
en prendre conscience
c'est à dire entre
1972 et 1981 elle a été très très peu
appliquée ensuite peut-être qu'il y
avait deux nouveaux magistrats nouvelle
formation nouvelle sensibilité générale
de l'opinion c'est probable elle a
commencé à être appliquée lentement
doucement
et pas toujours à bon escient et
quelquefois même en porte à faux ce qui
fait qu'on appelle à la souvent et pas
être pas été suivi donc oui il ya un
problème avec les magistrats pour qu'ils
aient une juste conscience de ce
problème comme sur d'autres sujets bien
entendu d'actualité mais ça c'est
nécessaire et c'est pour ça que je
faisais appel à l'école à l'éducation
nationale aux pouvoirs publics pour
qu'ils en parlent autant qu'ils parlent
souvent d'autres choses qui sont
peut-être moins essentiels dernière
question peut-être vous n'avez pas quand
même l'impression il est nécessaire ce
combat mais il est immense à l'heure des
réseaux sociaux ou la haine prolifère il
ya un texte de loi qui a été votée la
loi avia sur la haine en ligne qui
s'attaque aux plateformes mais qui crée
un parquet spécialisé on a un peu
l'impression que c'est david contre
goliath il ya une directive européenne
qui va être adoptée par le conseil qui
l'a été par le parlement et qui va
européen et qui va réguler cet espace
qui est devenu une jungle avec des
obligations qui sont imposés sur la
qualité de la modération sur la la la
rapidité avec lequel les textes les
propos délictueux seront retirés des
impôts d exiger d imposer pardon aux
plateformes et aux hébergeurs il va y
avoir une loi il ya déjà eu la loi
confortant les principes de la
république qui valurent une loi
certainement en application de cette
directive on est en train de s'organiser
donc la loi fax cet espace de jeunes
sous répondre à cela le respect de
l'autre de la différence la nécessité
même dans l'humanité de vivre dans l'est
différence c'est ce qu'il faut apprendre
aux jeunes si naturellement ils ne le
comprennent pas par eux mêmes et dans
leur cadre familial un dernier mot oui à
lévis dernier mot pour que l'on prenne
réellement
l'importance qu'on comprenne
l'importance de cette loi de 72 et du
délit raciste arrêtons de faire du
délinquant raciste un délinquant
d'exception qui est traité avec les
mêmes garanties procédurales qu'un
journaliste sortons la loi de 72 de la
loi sur la presse de 1881 et faisons des
délinquants raciste un délinquant
ordinaire avec des mêmes droits
je
l'appelle l'appel est lancé merci
infiniment je vous propose de rester
tous les deux avec nous pour accueillir
nos affranchissez lors de du parti pris
ce soir de richard wehrli ça va vous
intéresser il va nous parler de nos
démocraties qui sont bien fragiles après
l'assassinât de shinzo abe d'anciens
premiers ministres japonais et puis le
voyage dans le temps de thibaut enoch ce
soir ed hier aujourd'hui demain no 2 a
franchi au masculin bonsoir
les voici on va commencer avec vous
richard vous connaissez très bien le
japon puisque vous y avez été
correspondant le meurtre de l'ancien
premier ministre ciseaux ab d'une
violence inouïe une telle violence au
pays du soleil levant est aussi la
preuve pour vous de la fragilité extrême
de nos démocraties oui alors il faut
savoir que le pays du soleil levant
c'est un pays d'ordinaire très calme du
point de vue de la violence publique et
il faut comprendre surtout qu'ils
étaient shinzo abe au plus tôt à beesan
pour rependre la expression japonaise
habituel alors cet ancien premier
ministre nationaliste qui a été à la
tête du japon entre 2013 et 2020 il
était obsédé par la défense du japon et
par le choc annoncé avec la chine il
était pour beaucoup d'observateurs un
faucon engager résolument aux côtés des
états unis d'ailleurs les états unis ont
immédiatement déploré sa disparition il
avait en 2014 annoncé la possibilité que
les forces d'autodéfense japonaises
parce qu'on ne parle pas d'armé au japon
entre en guerre potentiellement aux
côtés d'un allié à savoir les états unis
ils étaient donc une personnalité très
exposé symbole de la domination aussi du
parti libéral-démocrate la droite
japonaise sur la politique de l'archipel
en clair c'était une cible alors le fait
qu'un tireur a priori solitaire les
visées avec son fusil artisanal en
pleine rue dans la ville de nara comme
on va le voir sur ces images
voilà et bien cela nous oblige à nous
pencher une fois encore sur la fragilité
de nos démocraties parce que le japon
c'est loin mais c'est une démocratie la
plus solide d'asie partenaires de
l'occident y compris dans la guerre en
ukraine alors ces images bien le
rappelle presque l'assassinât de john
fitzgerald kennedy à dallas au texas en
1963 de quoi alimenter à coup sûr les
théories du complot voir l'idée
peut-être d'une résurrection on n'en
parle pas encore d'un par un loup
solitaire de la secte aum vous vous
souvenez qu'ils allaient attaquer le
métro de tokyo au sahara le 8 juillet
1995 or shinzo abe a été tué le 6
juillet il y a pas tellement de
différence quatre ans pile après la
peine de mort infligée aux sept
dirigeants de la secte qui avait été
emprisonné et cette peine de mort elle a
été exécutée en 2018 alors frattini
était du japon feraient s'ils étaient de
toutes les démocraties et bien tout ça
paraît très lointain parce qu'on parle
du japon et d'ailleurs vous avez vu tous
les articles sur le thème au japon il ya
très peu d'armes c'est très réglementé
de fait les seuls qui ont des armes au
japon en général sont les yakuzas c'est
à dire les gangs mafieux que la police
tolèrent parce qu'ils font respecter
l'ordre mais en réalité c'est aussi la
démocratie japonaise qui est menacé
parce que shinzo abe était un politicien
certes critiqué mais qui avait pris des
positions extrêmement frontale sur un
certain nombre de sujets il a été tué
lors d'un meeting avant les élections
sénatoriales qui ont lieu ce dimanche 10
juillet c'est donc quand même la
démocratie nippone qui est blessé avec
cette question équivaut aussi dans nos
parages comment concilier le besoin de
proximité d'écouté de nos populations
qui sans cesse veux qu'on aille au
contact et en même temps les risques
encourus par les dirigeants de nos pays
même dont le très lointain et tranquille
japon merci beaucoup merci pour cette
chronique ce parti pris est richard on
et consacrera sans doute nos émissions
la semaine prochaine on enchaîne hier
aujourd'hui je vous fait voyager dans le
temps comme chaque semaine ce soit vous
nous parlez d'edf oui puisque vous
l'avez certainement entendu mercredi
lors de son discours de politique
générale la première ministre elisabeth
bord annoncé que l'état allait revenir à
100% au capital d'edf une
renationalisation
stratégique est nécessaire explique le
gouvernement pour être plus indépendant
sur le plan énergétique
une décision qui répond aux enjeux du
futur notamment le financement du parc
nucléaire mais au présent aussi car
l'entreprise va mal de très mauvais
résultats sont attendus pour 2022 en
raison de l'arrêt de la moitié du parc
nucléaire pour des problèmes de
corrosion et des opérations de
maintenance en raison aussi du bouclier
tarifaire dont la charge impact
largement les comptes de l'entreprise
résultat une dette qui frôle les 60
milliards il y avait urgence à ce que
l'état mette la main au portefeuille
donc en tout cas 17 ans après son entrée
en bourse est un retour au bercail
nationale pour df et donc les pilotes
d'une longue histoire à poil entreprise
ou une histoire qui a commencé au sortir
de la seconde guerre mondiale en 1946
exactement année où est votée à
l'assemblée nationale la loi sur la
nationalisation de l'électricité et du
gaz loi portée par un ministre
communiste marcel paul cette loi crée
edf établissement public qui nationalise
les biens des quelques 1400 entreprises
qui s'occupait alors d'énergie en france
dès l'après-guerre l'état prend donc la
main ce qui va lui permettre de lancer
le programme nucléaire civil choix
stratégique pour le pays dont la
première pierre est posée avec
l'inauguration de la centrale de chinon
c'était en 1961 regarder ce sont des
images de l'avenir que nous a apporté
cette semaine la chèvre non technique de
la première centrale nucléaire française
et des f1 sur le territoire de la petite
commune d'avoine près de chinon a
dévoilé le spectacle des centrales
électriques de l'âge atomique
alors la suite est marquée par un
développement rapide mais un tournant se
produit au détour des années 2000 c'est
l'europe qui impose la déréglementation
du secteur électrique et l'ouverture à
la concurrence conséquence edf change de
statut devient une société anonyme
prélude à l'ouverture du capital
l'ouverture alors présenté comme
indispensable écouter extrait du journal
de 20 heures de france 2 en 2002
pourquoi ouvrir le capital d'edf la fin
du monopole cela signifie pour odf
perdre des clients français l'entreprise
part donc à la conquête de nouveaux
marchés partout en europe mais aussi en
amérique du sud ou en chine des
acquisitions qui coûte cher en grande
partie financées par l'emprunt
car une entreprise publique ne peut pas
faire appel à des investisseurs
extérieurs résultat une dette de 22
milliards d'euros en ouvrant son capital
edf pourrait financer ses projets sans
creuser sa dette et nouer des alliances
avec des partenaires étrangers alors à
l'époque il ya un fort mouvement social
un des personnels auxquels doit faire
face un certain nicolas sarkozy alors
ministre de l'économie ce choix de la
privatisation en tout cas fut-elle
partiel est largement critiquée
notamment par un ancien premier ministre
lionel jospin écouter en l'espèce sur
edf c'est une faute majeure derrière le
dossier edf ya le dossier nucléaire il
ya tout le problème de la durée des
centrales de la reconstitution des
centrales de la création nouvelle
centrale et sa
seule une très grande entreprise
publique peut l'assumer il y va aussi de
notre indépendance nationale on a 17 ans
plus tard cet avertissement trouve une
certaine pertinence l'état revient donc
à 100% du capital retour à la case
départ et demain alors qu'est ce qui va
se passer avec cette renationalisation
quels enjeux vont devoir relever
l'entreprise alors la renationalisation
d'abord le gouvernement souhaite que ça
évite il y a deux options soit l'on
passe par une loi soit l'état rachète
directement en bourse les part manquante
coût de l'opération en tout cas six à
huit milliards les défis maintenant les
chantiers sont immenses edf va devoir
développer à la fois et rapidement le
renouvelables et le nucléaire pour
répondre à des besoins en électricité
qui vont augmenter de 35% d'ici 2050
pour ce faire emmanuel macron a fixé une
feuille de route en février dernier
alors côté renouvelables il faudra
financer la construction de 50 parcs
éoliens en mer en 30 ans doublé l'éolien
terrestre d'ici 2030 et multiplier le
solaire par dix d'ici 2050 côté
nucléaire deux chantiers extrêmement
coûteux d'abord la prolongation du parc
actuel entre 50 et 100 milliards sont
nécessaires selon les estimations et
puis la construction des ciseaux père au
minimum coût 50 milliards des chiffres
qui donnent le tournis en revenant à
100% du capital l'état se porte garant
de tous ces investissements ce qui va
faciliter leur financement leur pilotage
aussi un nouveau pdg devrait être nommé
rapidement en revanche une incertitude
demeure cette renationalisation est elle
durable ou temporaire deux ombres
planent celle de bruxelles d'abord qui
pourrait exiger des contreparties pour
respecter le droit à la concurrence et
puis liés à ces injonctions européennes
le scénario d'un découpage de
l'entreprise vous aviez peut-être
entendu parler du projet hercules prix
avait fait bondir les syndicats en 2019
il s'agissait de séparer l'entreprise en
deux entités d'un côté le nucléaire de
l'autre le renouvelable et la
commercialisation en gros l'une rentable
est l'autre nom est tout à fait possible
et même probable que l'état dans
quelques années remettent cette partie
rentable d'edf sur le marché l'histoire
des nationalisations et des
privatisations n'est peut-être pas
terminée merci beaucoup merci pour ce
point complet en archives hier
aujourd'hui demain le grand électricien
crossed et f merci infiniment
alain ternois re et bel anniversaire à
votre loi sur la lutte contre le racisme
merci mario stasi de la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire avec
jean pierre gratien très belle soirée
est très bon
[Musique]